Good enough is great.
Perhaps not a concept you'd expect to
hear at the business school, yet this
notion of good enough is great underlies
a lot of our entrepreneurial efforts.
The concept of minimally
viable product design
is critical for
bringing products to market.
In this approach, you strive to get your
product or service out there quickly so
that you can test and get feedback
to see where the true value lies.
Let me give you an example.
Imagine you're a baker, and
you want to bring your baked
goods to the broad market.
You have visions of crafting wonderful
cakes and pies to delight your customers.
Minimally viable product design,
MVP would suggest that rather than
starting with elaborate cakes,
you start by making cupcakes.
Cupcakes provide good value
to your potential clients.
They're relatively easy to make.
And they allow you to solicit feedback to
better understand how you can hone and
develop your products and
services for the future.
This notion of minimally
viable product design is
critical to your success in
growing your product in services.
It comes down to five key steps,
understanding the user requirements,
the problem space or
market that you're trying to deliver in,
the metrics you'll use to assess
the success of your offering,
you create designs, really quick product
versions to bring to the market,
and then you test and you iterate.
Fundamentally, the concepts involved
in MVP are things like prototyping,
understanding the needs and
iteration all to drive you towards value.
The key idea here in our talk
today is this fundamental belief
that the ideas in minimally viable product
design translate into our communication.
So I'd like to welcome you to a talk
on minimally viable communication
when good enough is great.
My name is Matt Abrahams.
I've been here at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business for
over a decade,
teaching strategic communication skills.
And I am thrilled to share with you
ways that we can use principles from
minimally viable product design
to apply to our communication.
Much like there were five
steps in the MVP process,
we have five steps in the MVC process.
It starts by looking at your audience,
understanding who they are and
what they need from your messaging.
You have to appreciate the context
in which you're communicating,
create a goal that is very specific for
that audience in context, structure and
design out your communication, and
then solicit feedback in iterate.
So let's get started and
understand each of these key components.
It all begins with your audience.
Who are you speaking to?
And more importantly,
what are their needs?
Many of us when we communicate,
make a fundamental mistake.
And we start from a position
of here's what I want to say,
rather than what does my
audience need to hear.
Now this sounds like verbal jujitsu
where I'm just moving words around, but
it is a fundamental
difference in our approach.
We need to understand our audience and
what they need to hear from us.
So there's several
questions I would like for
you to think about when you have
important communication to craft.
First and foremost,
what does my audience know about my topic?
Do they know a lot?
Or do they know a little?
We have all been victimized by
communicators who start too high level or
too low level for us.
Second, you need to think
about their attitudes relative
to the topic that you're discussing.
Are they in favor?
Perhaps they're not in favor
of what you're saying.
Or maybe they're agnostic.
They just don't know enough.
You also have to think
about resistance points.
What are the things that might
cause hesitation in your audience?
Is it what you're proposing costs
too much money, takes too much time,
requires too much effort?
We have to think about knowledge,
attitudes and resistance.
And from my colleagues here
at the business school,
we add psychological distance.
How far are you away from your audience?
Not physical distance, but
perhaps in an organization,
are you much more senior or
perhaps more junior to the person talking?
That matters in terms of what you say and
how you say it.
According to research from Near Halevy,
research from Zack Tortola tells us we
have to understand the relevance and
importance of what we're saying so that we
can motivate and influence our audience.
So thinking through our audience is
the first step in the minimally viable
communication process.
And this can go badly, in fact,
let me give you an example.
There is a durable goods company in
Northern Europe called Electrolux.
And many years ago,
they ran this ad campaign,
nothing sucks like an Electrolux.
This ad was an abysmal failure, why?
We don't like to buy things that suck.
You can imagine some advertising person
in their office thinking, I know.
We're going to suggest that our
vacuum cleaner suction is so
powerful that it caused
the Tower of Pisa to leak.
But they didn't understand their
audience down to the linguistic level,
nothing sucks like an Electrolux.
So we have to take the time as part of
our design process to think through
our audience at many levels
including linguistic.
Now let me share an example of where
understanding your audience actually was
very helpful.
And I borrowed this story from where I
first read it in the book Made to Stick by
Dan and Chip Heath, and Chip Heath
teaches here at the business school.
And in this inmate distinct,
they describe the story of Texas.
In Texas in the mid 1980s,
there was a huge littering problem,
trash and rubbish all over the place.
It didn't look good,
and it wasn't healthy.
So the government invested in a public
service campaign, featuring this guy.
And I know many of you listening
in today are of my vintage and
you might remember Woodsy the Owl,
give a hoot, don't pollute.
And Woodsy was placed on billboards,
television, and radio.
Remember this was the 80s,
there was no internet.
When I share this story
with my MBA students today,
they physically get disturbed
at the thought of no internet.
Something interesting happened though,
after two years of Woodsy
being on television, radio, and
billboards, littering got worse.
It was as if Texans were saying,
we don't like you Woody, and
they were throwing more
garbage all over the place.
This caused great concern.
So the government invested in
an effort to bring academics in to
help with the littering problem.
And the very first thing
the academics did,
Was try to figure out who
is doing the littering.
Now, for some of you,
this might not be surprising.
It turns out that most of the littering
was being perpetrated by men.
Not just any men but
men between the ages of 18 and 34.
And they went further beyond learning
who was doing the littering,
they looked into some of the attitudes and
beliefs that these people held.
And for any of you who have been
to Texas or grew up in Texas,
you know one thing is true about
Texas males in that age demographic.
They are very proud of being from Texas.
If they could,
they would make Texas its own country.
Based on knowing who was
doing the littering and
some of the attitudes,
they created this ad campaign.
If you've been to Texas, you've seen it.
It's still around today, 30 years later.
Don't Mess With Texas.
It's a play on words, don't mess,
meaning literally don't make a mess,
but also don't mess, I take great pride.
Within two years of this
ad campaign coming out,
they were able to reduce littering
in the state to up to 80%.
If you know anything about
social science research,
an effect size that large is unheard of.
By getting the right message to
the right people in the right way,
you can have a huge effect.
The take home message here is
take time to know your audience,
it is the first step in the minimally
viable communication process.
But it's not enough just to
know about your audience,
you also have to think about the context
in which you are communicating.
Whenever you communicate, there's
a context which includes many things.
Cultural elements, channel elements
like the technology you're using.
But I want to highlight
two that are critical for
bringing communication to your audience.
The first has to do with the time
of day you are communicating.
Right now it's my morning.
For some of you, it's your early afternoon
and for others, it's your evening.
That impacts what you bring to
our communication, your focus,
your willingness to collaborate,
your engagement.
Research by GSB Professor Baba Shiv
looks at our
neuro-chemical profile,
depending on the time of day.
In fact his research suggests,
if you're looking for
collaborative work, it's best to do
it early in the morning when people
are more open to collaboration based
on dopamine and serotonin levels.
Now that doesn't mean the only time
to collaborate is in the morning.
What it means though is if you're
doing it later in the day,
you might have to do
some team building and
trust building activities first to get
people to that place of collaboration.
Time of day matters when it
comes to your communication.
Another timing variable involved
in context is sequence.
We often prepare our communication as
if it will be received in isolation.
Yet we all live lives where we realize
we are constantly bombarded with
different communication messages.
Think about the sequence
of your messaging,
where are you in the interaction
that your audience experiences?
Think of it this way, if you're proposing
a new plan that involves investment
from your organization and
you're going into the executive committee,
following somebody who delivered bad news,
might that influence
the decision making process?
It could,
you need to think about that sequencing?
Similarly, what could you do to set
up others who come behind you and
follow you in your communication?
So context is equally
critical to think about.
I recently heard this quote that I love
that really reinforces the value of
thinking about your audience and
your context, it goes something like this.
Writing a high stakes communication
without thinking about your audience
is like writing a love letter and
addressing it to whom it may concern.
You would never do that.
Nor should you draft high stakes
communication without thinking about your
audience.
Into that idea I add, without thinking
about the context it's like taking
that love letter, putting it in a bottle,
throwing it in the ocean hoping
it lands in the right place,
you must equally focus on your context.
So the question becomes why, and
what's next in the minimally
viable communication process?
Once we think about audience and context,
we have to think about our goal.
All high stakes communication
must be goal driven, and
to my mind a goal has
three major components.
It's about information,
emotion, and action.
In other words,
what do you want your audience to know?
How do you want them to feel,
and what do you want them to do?
Know, feel, do.
Your goal is predicated on what you know
about your audience and your context.
So if the audience changes or
the context changes,
you might need to change your goal.
For this presentation I'm giving
you today, my goal is quite simple.
I'd like for
you to leave here knowing how minimally
viable product design processes
apply to your communication.
Further, I'd like you to
know the specific steps and
best practices in the minimally
viable communication process.
I want you to feel confident in your
ability to apply these processes and
ultimately to put them into practice
whenever you're bringing messaging to your
audiences.
Know, feel, do.
Take the time to figure out
your communication goal,
because this goal will come
back to help us later.
Not only does it direct what
we want to say going forward,
it also helps us assess our success.
It is critically important that
you take time to understand what
the success of your
communication would look like.
When I travel all over the world teaching
communication skills, I'll often ask,
how do you know if your
communication was successful?
And the number one answer I get is,
I got through it,
as if survival is the key
metric of success.
Of course, I think that's ridiculous.
You should be able to measure
the success of your messaging,
your communication,
based on the goal you set out with.
So a goal not only helps you figure out
what direction to take your messaging,
it also helps you assess your success.
Now once you have a goal in mind,
we then have to spend time ideating
before we can create our structure,
we have to be inspired to
think about what are the key themes and
ideas that I want to get across.
And this is where lessons
from Stanford's D school,
design school, can really come in handy.
There are myriad ways to get
creative in coming up with your
ideas that will feed into your messages.
Let me share a few that I like to use
as I'm creating my minimally viable
communication.
First and foremost there's old fashioned
brainstorming, most of us have done that.
When you just generate ideas without
bringing judgment to them at first,
it's a good idea to give
you some time constraints.
Research suggests time constraints
help with brainstorming.
But other techniques work well too.
One I'll often employ is to put
myself in a different perspective.
I'll ask myself how would a seven
year old Matt address this issue?
Kids are wonderfully creative, put
yourself in that creative playful mindset
and ask yourself how you would
approach this particular communication
challenge with the goal you have and
where would that lead?
Another way I like to brainstorm or
come up with ideas is to do a mind map.
So rather than listing things out which
can lead to chronological bullet point,
ideas and results.
Rather get graphic,
draw circles and arrows and
see if that can help you
come up with unique ideas.
And perhaps my most favorite way of
generating ideas is one I recently learned
from a colleague at the D school.
And that is using analogies,
think about situations that are similar
to what you're trying to communicate.
And what could you learn by exploring
those different situations.
Let me give you two examples of
what I mean by this, thinking and
creativity through analogy.
There was a hospital chain in
the Midwest that was interested in
improving their emergency room results.
And rather than going around
to other hospitals and
checking their best practices,
which I'm sure they likely did.
They actually went to a Formula One
pit crew and they observed what
a pit crew did to quickly get
cars back out on the race course.
And if you think about it,
a racing pit crew and
what happens in the Is really similar.
You've got time critical, sensitive,
urgent issues that have to be fixed and
resolved quickly.
And they learn many things by looking
at how the pit crew function.
For example,
most pit crews have kits set up for
different situations they
might find themselves in.
So let's say a tire blows out, they have
a whole set of materials set aside for
dealing with that one issue.
The hospitals in their ER's took
that idea and developed kits for
the different types of
emergencies they might see.
Another example is Apple,
when Apple opened up its retail stores,
they created the genius bars essentially
the tech support in the stores.
Rather than or in addition to looking
at top notch service organizations.
They actually went and explored how high
end hotel concierge services worked.
By using analogies, new ideas and
approaches can come to mind.
And this ideation can then help you
begin to create your communication.
So once you have your goal, which is
based on your audience and context,
you have to spend some time brainstorming.
And coming up with the information that
you want to communicate that will help you
achieve your goal.
Once you have those ideas in mind,
you have to crystallize them and
bring them into clear focus.
And I love the tool of 6 word stories
to help bring focus to your ideas.
Take all of the themes and
the creativity that you spent in
the ideation phase and
try to distil them down in 6 words.
And that 6 word narrative
becomes the driver for
the message design that you will create,
this is a focusing activity.
For this talk today,
my 6 word story is craft messages for
quick iterative feedback.
That was the narrative I used to help
me structure this entire presentation.
What's your 6 word story for
the messages you need to create?
The next step in the minimally
viable communication process,
once we've ideated and we've focused,
is to structure our messages.
Structure is absolutely critical for
your communication,
we have all been victimized by
people who ramble on and on.
I hope that's not happening right now,
when somebody is rambling,
it makes it really challenging for
us to focus.
We have to bring a lot of energy to focus
and what most of us do is we check out.
So what is it that we can do to
make it easier for our audience?
And that thing is to make sure
that you provide structure,
I learnt this a long time ago.
As an undergrad at Stanford,
I was a tour guide, and
one of the number one things
they taught us as a tour guide
on the Stanford campus is
never lose your audience.
You are a bad tour guide
if you get people lost,
how do good tour guides
keep people together?
They set their expectations and
that's one of the powers of structure,
structure sets your expectation.
Would any of you go on a tour with me
if I showed up and said, Hi, I'm Matt,
I'm your tour guide, let's go?
Some of you would because you're
adventurous but many of you would be like,
heck no, where are we going?
Why are we going there?
Do I have the right shoes on?
So by setting your expectations up front,
by structuring your tour,
you can relax and enjoy.
The other value that structure brings,
is structure helps us
to remember the information
that's being communicated.
Neuroscientists tell us that structured
information is actually processed more
fluently and efficiently.
Think about this,
how many of you can remember phone
numbers from when you were a kid?
Most of us can, now my kids today,
they don't have to remember phone numbers.
They just look at a picture and
push a button on their phone and
somebody else starts talking.
But in our day, we had to remember phone
numbers, here in the United States,
our phone numbers are 10 digits long.
It's hard to remember 10 digits,
if I gave you 10 numbers right now and
asked you to remember them for an hour.
Or a day, or a year or a decade or
in my case many decades,
that would be hard, so how do we do it?
We leverage structure,
we don't remember 10 digits, rather,
here in the United States,
we remember the three digit area code.
The three digit prefix and the four digit
number, that structure helps us remember.
So structure is something that can be
very useful to you as you communicate.
So, allow me to introduce you
to one of many structures and
when it comes to minimally
viable communication.
I believe this structure is perhaps
the most effective one you can use and
this structure is, the what?,
so what?, now what?
Structure, let me explain it and then let
me share with you how you can use it.
In this structure you start by talking
about what it is you are crafting ,it's
your message,
your idea ,your product ,your service,
whatever it is you are communicating.
The so what is why is it important or
relevant to the audience
that you are speaking to?
It could be to the audience directly,
it could be to the company,
it could be to society,
but it involves relevance.
And then finally, now what?
What comes next?
It has momentum built in, maybe the next
step is to watch a demonstration.
To take a taste of something, to set up
a next meeting, what?, so what?, now what?
Is a powerful way of
structuring your messages, why?
It's easier to remember,
you simply answer the three questions and
you get a structure.
Second, it has that relevance built in and
if something is relevant people
will pay more attention to it.
And they're more likely to remember and
act on it, and
it has that momentum, that now what step.
Helping you understand what
to do after the message.
So, as you are quickly crafting your
content to bring to your audience to
iterate, what?, so what?,
now what?, is your friend.
I'd like to take a meta moment here,
a timeout.
In my MBA classes, we do a lot
of this meta moment stuff, why?
It allows us to better
understand our communication and
I just want to point out that I just
explained what, so what, now what?
Using what, so what, now what, it's a
powerful concept for teaching information.
In fact, everything I've shared today
has been packaged in this structure.
I tell you what it is,
why it's important and
share with you how you can best use it.
So I encourage you to, once you've
spent some time getting creative idea,
in focusing your message to think about
how can I structure that message to
achieve that six word story over
arching approach that I have.
The final phase in our
minimally viable communication
process is to search for feedback.
The whole goal of minimally viable
communication just like minimally
viable product design is to iterate,
you need to test and get feedback so
that you can hone your messages.
Here you see on the screen,
something I remember from a kid as part
of a science lab in elementary school.
We had to build contraptions that would
allow an egg to fall from a rooftop
to the ground without cracking.
And we tested a lot of different ideas.
The winning idea was a parachute strapped
to the egg and that's what you see here,
we have to test, we have to iterate,
we have to ask for feedback and based on
that feedback, go through this process
again, and again until we have the message
honed in such a way that it can provide
the optimal value for our audience.
The minimally viable communication
design process can help you in many,
if not most, communication situations.
It starts by understanding your audience,
their knowledge level, their attitudes,
their resistance points,
the psychological distance between you and
them, and the relevance and
importance of what you're saying to them.
We have to think about the context, which
includes many facets, including timing,
time of day in sequence.
You have to spend time understanding
your goal, know, feel, do.
And that goal allows you not only to
focus your messaging and efforts, but
it also allows you to assess your success
in the final phase, that feedback phase.
And then we have to take
the time to structure, but
before we can structure we
have to ideate and focus.
Taken together,
this process of minimally viable
communication design can help
you get meaningful messages to
your audiences very quickly to
add value for you and for them.
If you'd like to learn more about
this type of communication, or
other aspects of communication,
I'd like to point you to a few resources.
I've written a book called speaking up
without freaking out that can help you
feel more comfortable and
confident in your communication.
I curate a website called
NoFreakingSpeaking.com
where my research and that of others
is there for you to check out.
And one of the greatest pleasures of
my life is I get to host a podcast for
the business school called Think Fast,
Talk Smart, where if we do our job right,
we use minimally viable communication to
bring relevant specific communication,
tools, and ideas to you from Stanford
faculty, mainly from the business school.
I invite all of you to continue to develop
and hone your communication skills.
And remember, good enough is great.
And with that, I'd now like to take some
time to listen to your questions and
ideas around how to become
a more effective communicator.
I'll agree on do we have some
questions that have come in.
>> We do.
So I had a question come in asking.
When it comes to leadership, a lot of
leadership coaches told us that although
leaders think that they have explained
enough their audience feels that they have
not received enough communication.
So how is that affected by a leader
trying to be minimally viable?
>> Yeah, I appreciate the insight
motivating that question which is
minimally viable doesn't
necessarily mean less information.
Minimally viable simply means that
you're testing out your messages to
understand what's needed for
your audience.
So I actually think minimally viable
communication resolves the problem that
the questioner is asking.
Because as a leader, if I have important
information to share, I go out and
iterate and test my messaging with some of
the people in the audience and understand,
am I saying enough?
Am I saying too much?
Is there more I need to bring?
And that will help me hone my message for
the broader audience.
In other words, I make those cupcakes and
I bring those cupcakes to
a few people in that audience.
I get their taste test and information and
then I prepare myself to bring the big
sheet cake to everybody in the audience.
So I actually think minimally viable
communication is the solution to
the problem that
the questioner was asking.
>> Our next question is,
isn't the TED Talk mentality
an enemy of your proposed approach?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Polished, endlessly reach,
rehearsed to the point of perfection.
>> Great, I love the challenge
that this is bringing in.
So when it comes to communication,
I separate communication into
two different approaches.
One is the planned communication.
And that's this TED Talk-like
approach where you plan,
you practice, you really try
to dial in the communication.
And then there is the more
spontaneous communication,
the communication that happens
off the cuff in the moment, etc.
And this approach, this mental approach
minimally viable communication can play
out in both sections, in both approaches
to your communication, clearly,
in the plan presenting you're practicing,
you're iterating, you're getting
feedback and you're leveraging a lot of
the tools that I mentioned in the talk.
In a spontaneous speaking situation,
again, most of our communication,
you can still leverage
many of these principles.
Immediately think about your audience and
their needs.
Consider the context you're speaking in.
What is my goal in this moment?
And then structure messages to answer it.
So the same process can
apply in real time.
When the question I just answered came in,
I immediately thought,
who am I talking to?
I'm talking to a bunch of alumnus
from the business school.
I thought about this context
of it being virtual, and
the situation where you're hoping to
learn something of value you can apply.
And I immediately thought of my goal.
What do I want you to know, feel and
do as a result of my answer,
to your question and
that fed into the way I answered it.
So, in other words, I applied these
specific, the processes I went through,
into how I handled the spontaneous
situation of answering the question.
So the answer boils down to there
are two fundamental different types of
communication, spontaneous and plain.
And what we talked about applies to both.
Now I heard some value judgment
in that question, which is,
isn't that TED Talkie overly rehearsed,
scripted approach?
Something that is not to be desired in
perhaps everyday business communication.
Well, I think at the extremes
that's probably true, but
the notion of being planned, prepared,
and iterating I think can help for
both planned and spontaneous speaking.
Think this might be related
to what you just said and
you may have already answered it.
But, how does the ideation,
iteration and practice,
practice practice, effect authenticity?
>> Yeah, so authenticity is critical.
So when it comes to your presence.
It's really about confidence,
credibility and authenticity.
And you want to walk that
fine line of being prepared,
but not being over prepared.
And that's why in the work I do here
at the business school in terms of
the strategic communication classes,
I teach and co-teach.
It's all about teaching
fundamental best practices.
And giving students opportunities to
explore and test those best practices.
So that you can then
internalize what works for you.
So you can develop your own style.
I like to use the analogy from sports.
All of us at some point in our life
learned how to swing some kind of sporting
implement.
A bat, a club, a racket and
we learn some foundational principles
that will help us be good at doing that.
But if I were to look at any of you
swinging one of those implements,
you wouldn't look slightly different than
the way I do it the way other people do it
based on your experience,
your expertise, your age or injuries.
It is finding the foundational
principles and honing them for you.
That leads to your authenticity.
So these foundational principles that
I covered today audience, context,
goal, ideation, focus,
structure, feedback,
those foundational principles
you have to internalize.
Take from different areas and different
experiences hone it for yourself and
that will allow you to be more
authentic as you deploy them.
So I certainly don't want everybody
to speak the same way to structure
messages the same way.
But I do think there is value by going
through a fundamental process to help you
come up with those messages.
I think that only bolsters your
authenticity rather than taking
away from it.
>> Great, thank you.
We have a question here asking
what happens after MVC?
How does one then do
the full on communication?
>> Thank you so this is only
the beginning this is to help you
figure out what to say you must
then focus on how you say it.
And you have to focus on the channel
through which you deliver it.
So we have to think first
I have this message.
What's the best way to get
that message to my audience?
Is it a multi-channel approach?
Is it an individual conversation or
dialogue?
So the next step is to think about
how do I deploy that message.
And again, you can iterate and
tests and figure that out.
And then you also have to focus on your
nonverbal presence how do you actually
deliver the message you can have
the best well crafted honed message.
But if it's delivered poorly that can get
in the way so I'm going to wax poetic just
for a couple minutes because I have
a lot of thoughts on nonverbal presence.
First, you have to make sure you
are comfortable and confident.
And some of the resources I pointed to at
the end of what I said can help you in
that way.
There are many tools that you can use to
feel more comfortable and confident in
your communication and I encourage
you to take the time to work on that.
In all the strategic communication classes
taught here at the business school,
we start with confidence building.
Once you have a foundational layer of
confidence, level of confidence in what
you're doing, you then have to think
about how you show up to deliver.
And I'd like to give you three bits of
advice about your nonverbal presence.
First is what you do with your body.
There are three key
concepts with your body.
You want to be big, you want to be
balanced and you want to be still.
Nervous people make themselves small,
they retreat in person I step back,
in a virtual world.
I sit far away so
you don't see my face as much.
We want to be big and present.
A great way to help yourself be big is
simply to take your shoulder blades,
your scapula, bones and
your back Pull them down when I pull them
down towards my waist I get broader.
Now I'm not bringing my elbows back and
puffing out my chest rather I'm
just pulling those shoulder blades down
that helps me look big and confident.
It also tightens up
the muscles in my neck so
my head is straight many of us tilt
our heads and tilting your heads when
you're in one on one interaction listening
is actually a great thing to do.
But when you're trying to command
confidence delivering an important
message, you want your head
to be straight, not tilted.
And this body posturing will help and
clearly shifting and rocking and swaying
can be very distracting, so big, balanced
and still in terms of your body posture.
The second thing to think about
is eye contact in North American
culture where I am today eye contact
is expected we expect people to
look us in the eye when I'm in
person I will segment my audience.
Instead of trying to look at every person
individually, I'll create quadrants and
I'll look in the back part of the room or
the front part of the room.
When I'm virtual, I train myself to
look at the camera as I'm speaking.
Because as I look at the camera,
it looks like I'm looking at you,
rather than looking down at all of your
images that I see on the screen and
thank you to those of
you showing your video.
So, we want to make eye contact.
And then finally,
when it comes to nonverbal presence,
we have to think about our voice.
Your voice is a wind instrument just
like a trumpet or clarinet, a saxophone,
the more air you put through it,
the more you can do with it.
We need to vary our voice.
Our brains are wired to habituate.
Anything that stays the same.
We stopped paying attention to it.
So you need to vary your voice to
keep people involved and engaged.
Now for some of us, that's hard.
We speak in a more monotone, mano rate
way, a great tool to help you have
more variation in your voice is to insert
emotive words, adjectives and adverbs.
If you need some help come back to
campus we have this lovely adverb wall.
Some of you have seen it on the campus,
insert some of those adverbs
into what you're saying.
I would never come to you and say,
I'm really excited to be here.
No I would say I'm really excited to
be here those emotive words invite and
invoke that variation in my voice.
So to answer the question what comes
after minimally viable communication and
you have your message crafted in and
honed and dialed in for maximal value.
You then have to think about
the channel through which you will push
that message out.
And then how do you deliver it in terms of
your nonverbal presence, big balanced and
still make eye contact if you're in North
American culture, in vary your voice.
That was a long winded answer, but
hopefully helpful to thinking about what
comes next after this process
we talked about today.
>> Perfect, yes and actually, you answered
another question that had said asked for
some tips when it came to
virtual communication.
So I think that
>> And
I add a couple more though
if somebody wants to listen.
>> Absolutely.
>> Let me share a couple other tips about
nonverbal about virtual communication.
This is something that we have
all had to learn a lot about.
And interestingly, some new exciting
research is coming out to help us.
A couple things, one, you want to make
sure that you fill half your screen.
Many of us as I alluded to earlier,
stand really far away from our cameras.
We are wired to pay
attention to people's faces.
We read a lot of information
of people's faces.
And if we can't see somebody's face,
we feel uncomfortable.
So fill your screen with half your body,
so half the screen should be you.
Second make sure that you are well lit.
Again, if we want to see people's faces,
we have to be able to see you.
Many people, Look like they are in the
witness protection programme when they do
virtual presenting.
They're in the dark, they're in
the shadows, light things up and
it doesn't have to cost a lot of money.
I mean, you can tell, if you talk to
any teenager, ask them about TikTok and
ring lights, they'll wax poetic and
they'll tell you how you can get
these different lights to light up.
But you can actually just run down to a
hardware store, get some mechanics lights,
the kind of lights a mechanic would clip
to your hood, to look at your engine and
that will work just as well.
Another thing is raise your camera up so
it's eye level with you.
Many of you when we do virtual
communication we use laptops and
the laptop typically sits lower than we
are so the angle is up under our chin.
Nobody looks good from this angle,
in fact when I was a kid,
if we wanted to scare people at night we
would shine a flashlight underneath our
chin to look scary,
that's how some people look.
Get a book, a box, a stand,
raise your laptop or your camera up so
it's eye level with you, and then the last
bit of advice is many of these tools,
Zoom, Meet, WebEx, et cetera, Teams.
They have recording capabilities.
Record yourself practicing and watch it.
It is incredibly painful
to watch ourselves.
We make all of our MBA students do it
in our strategic communication classes,
they have to record and
watch themselves, it is yet
the single best teacher to see
how you are communicating.
So, make sure you can be seen, raise
your camera, get some good lighting and
record yourself, that's going to help
you be a better virtual communicator.
>> So next question is,
how has social media, Facebook, Twitter,
TikTok changed your concepts?
Do you expect more changes
in the near future?
>> Wow,
there's a lot that could be said here, so
different modalities of communication
have clearly affected how we do
strategic communication within
organizations for sure.
And the one how ubiquitous they are.
But also how quickly you can put messages
out there really necessitates this
minimally viable communication approach.
There will be times where you just
have to get messages out quickly and
you can use these social media tools
as a way of testing your messages and
as the endpoint of the process as well.
We spend a lot of time in our strategic
communication classes talking about what's
the appropriate channel for
the message you're trying to get across.
And often, these different types of
social media and the other communication
tools slack et cetera,
need to be considered as viable channels.
So we have to think about,
what does the channel bring to
the way in which we craft the message.
If you're on Twitter,
you have constraints.
How many words you can use,
you have to think about it.
It does the message, make better sense to
have visual if you're using Instagram,
for example, so it requires you to bring
in other questions in the design process.
What I foresee coming forward more and
more, types of social channels for
us to communicate in, I don't know how
many of you are aware of something like
a clubhouse or other things where it's
an audio only social media platform.
We're going to see more and more
opportunities for us to communicate and
other tools and
we have to think about our messaging and
make sure that our messaging is specific
and tailored to the different channels.
Again, the context piece in that process
I went through for minimally viable
communication is really about considering
those elements of the channel.
So I'm excited by it.
I think it's fascinating.
I love teaching folks who
are younger than I am.
I learn a lot about different
ways of communicating.
And we all have to embrace
these different channels.
Clearly, there are liabilities involved,
we have to think about it, there ethics
involved, you need only look at the news
to see issues around social media, but
they are channels for getting our
messages out and we have to explore and
in some cases exploit them.
>> You may have already answered
this by mentioning practice,
iteration, watching your recordings
as embarrassing as that might be.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
how do you train students to
speak with more confidence?
>> Mm-hm, yeah.
So confidence is something I've
spent a lot of my career focused on.
It's research I did all the way
back in undergrad and grad school.
It is critical to focus on confidence.
Confidence is the biggest barrier to
people sharing their opinions and
voices and I firmly believe we need to
hear from as many people as possible,
in our dialogue to understand and
be better at what we do.
So to my mind, confidence is really
about focusing on two issues.
One is the symptoms that happen to us
physiologically and mentally when we
get nervous in our communication, and then
looking at some of the sources of anxiety.
And I invite you to check out
not only that book I wrote or
the website no freaking speaking
to see lots of my thoughts and
thoughts of others on this, but
let me give you just two quick examples.
One in each camp.
The symptoms, and
the sources to help build confidence.
When it comes to symptoms,
our body is invoking the fight, or
flight response to our communication.
I believe and others who study this that
there's an evolutionary component to why
we get nervous, our bodies experience
speaking in front of others as a threat
and respond in kind and
I'm happy if we have time later.
In this session or in other ways to go
more into that perspective why we see
it as a threat, but as a result
of that threat we invoke fight or
flight, our heart rate elevates,
we begin breathing more shallow.
A lot of adrenaline is pumped which causes
us to shake and perspire et cetera.
The single best thing you can do to
short circuit the fight or flight
response invoked through your anxiety
around communication is deep breathing.
Deep belly breaths can calm down and
slow down your autonomic nervous system.
Now, I recently learned and this is,
I love doing the thing fast talk smart
podcast because I learned so much.
I had a cognitive neuroscientist
here at Stanford.
His name is Andrew Huberman, super bright
guy if you ever get a chance to check out
his work, he was a guest on the podcast
and we were talking about stress and
how to reduce stress.
And I said, well,
everybody says deep breathing helps.
Is that true?
He goes, absolutely, but
it's not the inhale.
And that rocked my world for
years, decades.
I've been telling people take a deep,
inhale a deep breath.
It's not the inhale that helps you relax,
it's actually the exhale.
So, the rule of thumb, or
shall I say the rule of lung is this,
to use deep breath to calm yourself down.
You want your exhale to be
twice as long as your inhale.
And again,
if we have extra time now or later, or
you can just listen to the podcast,
you'll learn why this is.
But if you take a slow three
count in to calm yourself down,
make sure that your exhale is six count
and you only have to do it two or
three times to actually
take the benefits so.
To manage symptoms, probably the best
thing you can do, deep breath, focus on
the exhalation, from a symptoms point
of view, from a sources point of view,
the things that actually make us nervous,
there's a lot that we can focus on.
Some of you might have heard me deliver a
talk that I did at a reunion several years
ago now called Think Fast Talk Smart.
The name of the podcast
came from that talk,
where I talk about one source of anxiety
which has to do with the fact that many of
us are made nervous by the goals
we're trying to achieve.
Whenever you communicate, you have a goal.
In fact, I encourage you to create a goal.
And many of us can be made nervous by
the thought of not achieving that goal.
So we begin to get nervous about
a potential negative future outcome.
I'm not going to get the good grade.
I'm not going to get the funding.
I'm not going to get the support.
We're worried about not
achieving our goal.
That's the source of the anxiety, a way to
mitigate that source, to reduce the impact
of that negative potential future
outcome is to become present oriented.
And in that video, I talk a lot about what
you can do to become present oriented.
For example, do something physical, take a
walk, do some exercise, listen to a song,
or a playlist, or the one that I like to
encourage people to do, is to start at
the number 100 and count backwards by
a challenging number like 13s or 17s.
All of those activities bring
you into the present moment,
which distract you from worrying
about a future consequence.
So, how do you get more confident?
You tackle both your symptoms and
your sources.
And there's a lot more
I could say about that.
But those are examples, I give you one
example of how to manage a symptom by deep
breathing and how to manage a source
trying to become present oriented.
Long-winded answer, but
a really important issue.
>> If you're doing a presentation for
which there is a somewhat standardized set
of expectations for the format or
the content, so for example,
a start-up team is pitching a potential
investor adopt your approach.
>> Yeah, so there are often situations
where there are expectations for
the structure of the communication
like an investor pitch or
you're presenting your research or
your findings,
there are often expectations around
the structure of the message.
Yet the content that goes into
that message I think would benefit
very directly from what we talked
about in terms of minimally
viable communication design.
So the structure might be set.
So for example in a pitch deck,
there's an expectation that you'll
start by talking about the problem,
you'll introduce your team, you'll talk
about the total addressable market, etc.
But how you approach that,
what you say about that market, or
how you define and frame the problem,
all of that can be rapidly prototyped and
tested to figure out the best way for
this particular audience.
So I think that those structures
can actually be helpful going into
a pitch where the person says, in your
pitch, you must do these seven things,
that's wonderfully helpful.
That's very insightful information about,
here, the person is telling me how they
want to hear my message,
they are telling me how to structure it.
Great, now I'm going to iterate
as best I can to figure out for
each one of those identified steps,
slides or parts of the presentation,
how can I maximize the value of
what I say for each of those steps.
So I actually think the structure given
can be very helpful to the process
we walk through
>> This may be related to that but
is the call to action component required
and the example given here is that
our alum as a volunteer in the National
Park likes to import knowledge and
perhaps some emotion but he feels it
might be a little too preachy when he
gives us action, so any thought for-
>> First, thank you for
the work you do in the National Parks.
I and my family have benefited from,
I mean, enjoyed going in and
learning from the people who are there,
so thank you for that work.
You don't always have to
have a call to action.
I would like for you though to consider,
should I have a call to action?
What are the advantages and
disadvantages of doing that?
And then make a judgment call.
So I share in the process,
I introduced the idea of where
you would put one, that now what.
But you don't always have to invoke it.
Again, you know your audience, you know
who you are and whether it works best for
you, but we'd like you to consider what
would a call to action sound like.
And there are calls to action that
are less directive and less preachy.
It could simply be thank you for your time
and for showing your passion for nature
and the environment, and I encourage
you to keep focus on the environment,
it's very important, that's a very
soft way of giving a call to action.
So again, it's not always required, I do
think it's important to think should I and
if I were to do that what would it sound
like and what are the advantages and
disadvantages of doing so.
>> Perfect.
>> A couple of quick set of questions.
>> Yes.
>> Facts, standing versus sitting,
what do you choose?
>> I choose standing, I'm standing now.
I stand for two reasons.
One, it helps me focus,
when I sit I get distracted more easily.
And two, standing allows me to use my full
body more, it allows me to be taller so
I can get more air into my lungs and
I find it helps me with what
I call vocal stamina, the ability
to speak for long periods of time.
If you stand though,
I recommend a couple things, one,
you want to make sure that sway and
rock and lean.
So it comes down to your foot position,
you want your feet to be parallel,
underneath your shoulders.
If your feet are splayed
out like a penguin or
a duck which is how many of us stand,
it opens up your hips and
it invites this swaying
which is very distracting.
If you know you do sway and
rock a bit when you present standing and
you're doing it virtually, get a stool, or
a box, or a book, put one foot up on it.
There is no way you will sway or
rock if you have one foot up on a stool,
you'll literally fall over if you try.
So I like to stand.
And what else, if you sit, that's fine.
The big thing about sitting is you want to
make sure you are in a chair that is
either locked down or cannot swivel a rock
because many of us will sway or swivel.
And many chairs have armrests and
when you're sitting,
you look like you're a robot because your
hands are just naturally placed here so
remove or lower those armrests so
you can use your arms more naturally.
>> Great, and what are your thoughts
on one camera, multiple cameras?
>> [LAUGH] So I am a simpleton.
It is very hard for
me to deal with just one camera.
If you are in a situation where
you have assistance in help,
then multiple cameras
might be interesting.
Again, it's novel, it can change
things up and change perspectives,
it's hard to manage.
I thought what you were going to ask,
not one or two cameras,
I thought you were going to say one or
two screens.
And I have a different opinion on screens,
I do think having multiple
screens can be helpful.
Today, I have two screens that
I'm able to manage and watch,
that allow me to keep track of
where my presentation is and
where you are in terms of how
you're moving through it.
So screens are different,
you do need to practice, and
get comfortable with them, but I myself
use multiple screens in only one camera.
>> Thank you so much, Matt.
In the last couple of minutes,
I would like to ask you if you have any
good recommendations, books or resources,
around increasing
confidence when speaking?
And also, is there a way for us or
companies to engage you as a coach or
consultant?
>> Well, thank you for
all those questions.
So I do believe the speaking up without
picking out book is a book that can
be very helpful to people who want to
become better communicators especially
building confidence.
The book was written for that, the book
was written for Stanford MBA students in
mind so those of you who have been here or
are here hopefully can benefit from that.
The book I mentioned earlier when I
talked about the Don't Mess With Texas ad
Made to Stick, I think is a wonderful
book around communication skills and
can be very helpful.
There are lots of videos and
resources out there to help,
I've tried to curate a lot of those
on the no freaking speaking site.
In terms of reaching out to me,
I am very happy to help alum and students
in any way I can, my email address can
be found on the the GSB faculty website.
It's also here, I'll put up my my screen
again so you can see my email address.
But I'm very happy to reach out,
I co-founded a consulting
practice called Bold Echo.
We do this work out in the corporate
world if that can be of help.
I really just encourage all of you
to focus on your communication.
Communication is critical.
We saw through the pandemic
how communication can be
incredibly important to keeping our
businesses connected and thriving, and
our personal lives connected and
thriving and I hope minimally viable
communication that approach can
help you hone your communication.
So thank you for listening, and if I
can be of service, please let me know.